c-span is brought to you by your cable
or satellite provider
janmi what is freight train number nine
it's train number nine is the special
train the the carriage that transports
the food and other things that only go
into the deal leader
and very selective group of few people
in the party so that change that they
don't even let normal people even go in
even the police they have to get
examined to even enter that carriage
with the other trains
and i think that was a train my father
used it to transport this copper and the
other commodities because that's where
the police cannot even come and just
check things unlike other train like
carriages
so only
only the kim family was allowed to have
the contents of train number nine what
kind of things were on that train do you
think
uh as far as i heard like uh i remember
when i saw this a big uh
pear and apple it was really big
and one of the that police and the
person who was carrying that kind of
store one of them i think and gave to us
and they were like having this special
food that grew grew in a very special
environment
and i in north korea the sugar is very
rare thing
and i heard that those plants even get
the sugar water
and that's why i think it was almost a
myth for us that how these even foods
are being produced
because those are not just normal food
that we transport to pyongyang
and they i think generally was more food
related items they were transporting
from there to pyongyang young me in your
book in order to live
you write
that you would have done anything for a
bowl of rice yeah
anything what does that mean
i think
yeah now i'm in this world where i'm
eating salad that's how i know that i am
being adjusted in this world like to me
the salad meant like a rabbit food
i was so offended like when i came to
america that people say we pay money to
buy these plants i think that's what
rabbits said
i had to eat them because i was starving
when i was young
i i i think for me it's like hunger was
just never a hunger
it was all it meant a death
that it was a daily life for me to see
people for hunger
that when you're hungry it's not just a
just you're hungry
it's a direct relate to your life that
your entire existence
until this day i have this uh food
some obsession that i get panic attack
if i know that i don't have food with me
and yeah it's scary for me to even go to
pet camping i have to know how easily
can i access the food
and when i eat right now even to this
day that i wouldn't eat as much as i can
even though it makes me sick because i
know when i was young i did not know
when i was going to have another
opportunity to eat again so when i had
that chance i had to eat as much as i
can
for survivor
so that's i think how different like le
is
i have the relationship i have food is
very different than most of people i
think here or like my friends
you also write in your book that you
needed special permission to eat beef in
north korea
yeah in north korea you know we know
this the darkest place on earth we don't
have 24 hours electricity we don't have
automobiles or other things to work in
the farm the government owns cows
we the individuals cannot own things
socialists that we don't own house or
anything it's all owned by the state
and so cultures belong to the state
and the the one of the execution that my
mom saw was a man who had tb and he ate
the cow he he killed a cow in the farm
and he was executed for that so our
lives in north korea are less very than
animals
and
so that some of the cause they we do
permission is like sometimes that cow
dies from the disease
i was too old and died then government
sometimes distributed to people but i
never like tasted cow when i was in
north korea so i never knew like how it
tastes like i never had a steak never
knew even what that was
what do you remember about making the
decision to defect from north korea
when was that idea formed
this slightly formed
when i was
more in early 2000s
that's when things were very desperate
in my family that we were not able to
find food and it was a spring and when
you talk about not finding food
would you go days or a day without
eating
uh
it's it's like sometimes we do have food
every day and sometimes
and everyone's like we have many days
without food but you eat like a few so
if you have a potatoes outside
it gets frozen then it becomes really
dark with black color
then that's why we ate like a one or two
potatoes a day
and we can say that that's what i was
having vermeer but that is not enough
nutrition certainly for a growing child
or anyone if you just eat like one this
is like oman two of the potatoes but we
were like running out of that frozen
potatoes the normal potatoes are too too
expensive that we cannot afford that and
supposedly the government has to feed us
and give us russian but they didn't the
regime choose to starve us because they
will not control the population
and what you're able to get is that my
father was trading this black market
selling sugar copper the commodities
and then with that money we could find
this
frozen potato because it's cheaper than
normal potato
and if you can find some like grains and
other things and in the summer time i go
to like a field and catch the
grasshoppers
and that's the source of protein for me
and eating dragonflies and a lot of
plants
and
and even those things are so scarce
people everyone's looking for food in
the mountain everyone is looking for
food like food interference
so even this plant is a real competition
to get them because like now what the
estimate like 10 million people are
starving in north korea out of 25
million
and even the rest of people are just
able to barely make in their life but 10
people 10 million is like
very managed
and a lot of people dying still to this
day dying from starvation
okay so you made
tell me about the decision-making
process to
get out of the country yeah so the
decision-making process is that i did
not have internet so obviously i did not
know what was happening outside of the
rest of the world but the advantage that
i had was leaving the border town of
north korea that's so close to china so
if you see north korea from the
satellite it's the darkest place on
earth we do not have 24 hours
electricity so i could see the
electricity from coming out of china and
that's how i just like assumed that if i
go to china i might find some like
bottle rice
and that was the only hint i had i had
no idea what was going to happen if i
escaped because i had to go somewhere so
i don't die from the starvation
what do you remember about seeing the
lights
in is it chiang bai china yes
what do you remember about seeing the
lights and the fireworks and even the
food smells you talk about would drift
over to north korea
it you know i had to sing the songs like
nothing to envy
the regime told us that we have nothing
to end with in this world
at that point all i felt was just envy
that i envied people who was in that
light
that i am with the people who was across
the border that the river i couldn't
believe how that one stream of river can
determine someone's life that much
that one people because i was born in
this side of the river i had to be
starved
and be a slave but because other people
were born in the front side of the river
they had food to eat like that and have
the electricity have the paved roads
have the cars
it was a it was a hell and the
heaven exists at the same time
and that's all i feel like just envy
them
that
what did it cost your family
to come across that river
be smuggled across that river that was
the cause of being sold and being sexual
slaves to a chinese man
for how long
almost two years
yeah
that's what the
kids say what north korean women choose
to do
they escape
the
terror oppression and hunger
and the price for them to be
get out of north korea means go to china
and what it means is being being soared
and being raped
and being tortured and even that they
are in a threat of the being
sent back to north korea to get killed
and being punished
and that's how they are estimated or
around the 300 000 skin defectors hiding
in china
and our slaves like myself
these people by a man and being raped
every single day
young me
was it worth the price
yeah
i mean
of course
it
i'm the only one of the lucky ones who
made it
so many people
paid
more enormous price than i did
and never able to reach
what i have here
but
of course i mean what i
have food and
i have passport to come to las vegas
and whatever i talk to right now no one
is going to execute me for this
this is what human beings should be so
i i will do the exactly the same thing
if i born again i would do everything i
could to be free and fight for my rights
in your book in order to live you talk
about
the fact that you thought the kim family
could read your mind
that's the
it's like north korea is one of the 10
religions in the world they copied the
basically the bible
they told us that our dear little kimier
song created this nation and freed the
whole humanity from the american masters
and he gave his beloved son to serve us
that was kim jong-ir and they say their
body dies but their spirit never dies
they are with us for the rest of our
life
that they came with our thoughts they
can do miraculously the universe chose
them
so i i mean i had no internet i had no
other information to know that they were
just human beings
they were ridiculous i did not know that
they were not gods
but young me park you write in your book
that this 1960s and 1970s were a very
different time than when you grew up
yeah was it a paradise in the 60s and
70s
it was not paradise people were being
still persecuted they have no
idea of concept of freedom of speech or
expression or the movement or religion
but they were not actually starving that
much they were
they were like not massive like millions
of people dying from starvation even
though they were persecuted for
political reasons
the problem right now in north korea is
not only they have no political rights
they don't have basic rights
that requires people to be alive
that i i'm not even asking for the
humanity the freedom of regulation or
movement a lot of things
just like can we feed these people
why we are throwing away so much food
like our problem in america now is
having too much
everyone stressed out but all my friends
are stressed about going on diet
and
i never knew
that was a thing that human beings can
do what do you mean a diet
and in north korea the most charming
person is kim jong kim and
kim jong-un
if you have a big belly and board you're
a very charming person
not many people are like that most
people are starving
so if you are having big belly and that
we we really like think they are like
very attractive people
so
i think that's what like i am so
obsessed with this regime is that even
though kim jong-un has so much resources
to build this news
and run the country he was educated in
switzerland that he knows so well that
he cannot be a god if he opens up that's
why he choose to start people so he can
control this population
is it inevitable that the kim dynasty
continues in today's world of the
internet and instant communications
i do think people are changing in north
korea the defectors like myself who
escaped we have relatives left we send
information back at home we still remain
in touch with them we call them through
this border smuggled phones in in north
korea
and we keep sending this news of freedom
and human rights
so now they are estimating around 75 of
north korean people have access outside
of information
and it's been only happening last 20
years
with this new spread of information if
more people escape and come and be like
myself be a sport person and pressuring
international community that they need
to hold this dictator accountable
and that you know north korea is one of
the countries abusing human slavery they
send they they enslave the entire
population
and this awareness going on
and the international society pressures
on and there's under grasp like which
level of this pressure that we send
information we rescue people then it's
inevitable for them to
collapse
i don't see any how they're going to
continue this same lie again and again
that they are gods and why we are making
movies like the
interview like in north korea i thought
if i ever think about bad things about
the dear leader i thought i was going to
be punished but look at the movie
interview that sony made
that we assassinated the dictator did
those people got cared no this is a
dictator and that's why it's important
for us to let the north korean people
know that they are slaves and they can
be like us
your mother was pretty loyal
north korean correct yep very lawyer
yeah she was uh
she when kim son died the first kim died
she did not know
how the earth was going to spin
she thought that was the end of universe
and
a lot of even actually north koreans
after they even they escaped
in my case when i escaped to china even
i was being raped and i'm suffering so
much at the age of 13 when people are
saying that because of your politics
you're like kim is so bad you guys are
doing like being
this way i said like what are you
talking about your bastard
he's a great leader the people working
for him is bad he's a great great god
that's what i did because i was so
brainwashed
but my mom now knows about truth and now
i know about the truth
i think the only thing that i want to
make sure
when i talk to people is that
lie doesn't have power
we should not like scared of lies that
the media in the west that's the one
thing i'm so sad about is that we
demonize
and look we dehumanize north korean
population
we kind of portrait them as a robot
who's brainwashed who's hopeless who
cannot understand the idea of freedom
and
democracy that is not true look at south
korea it's the same country it's been
same country for thousands of years the
system is a problem not the people
and when we try to say the people are
the problem they they are stupid why
they are not like why the one question
guys like when people say so why didn't
you fight why didn't you just like why
did you put up with all this thing and i
say like so if you don't know that you
are slaves
how do you demand to be free
and that's what's wrong with the north
korea the people did not know that they
are isolated they don't know that they
are slaves
so if we let these northern people know
that they are slaves and there are words
like
this exists the human rights human
dignity freedom everything can be
respected the people in north korea
fight for that
young me park did you
realize that you weren't happy as a
child
did you have a happy childhood at all
i
honestly
i was very happy
i mean it was cause i would never say i
was hungry i always thought i might die
from starvation
but because i had the very loving
parents
that they
they prioritized me everything that i
was so grateful for
but i was very hopeless child because i
couldn't dream
i mean in north korea you have your
classes when you're born into your faith
is determined before your birth before
like you i was born my father's status
my grandpa my great grandpa all their
family record made me into my class in
the society
and as a child no one asked me like what
i want to become like
when i'm becoming adult
so in society it was so hard and all i
remember when i looked at north korea
it's just great
there's no color in north korea in my
memories everything is great
that's how public that my childhood was
like starving and hungry and desperate
and scared that even the birds and mice
can hear me and that's the first thing
my mom told me that don't even whisper
because the birds of mine's gonna hear
me but despite that i think the most
important thing was a family to me
that i still like thinking back my
childhood at least i was loved and i
would cherish in my household
where is your family your sister your
mother your father
today my father died from the colon
cancer he got the prison in north korea
and
where did he die in china in china
during before the basic only begins in
2008
and my mother in south korea
in the countryside
and i got reunited my sister older
sister who we were separated for like
seven years
and she's in south korea
studying university now
and i am in america so we three of us in
freedom
are you a citizen no i'm not i i'm a
permanent resident and yeah are you
going to go for your citizenship of
course
it's not
if this country like would let me i
would be honored
yeah
what year did you cross that river into
chiang mai
it was 2007 march 31st how old were you
13.
you were in the hospital
my mother remained at my bedside because
we had no money to bribe them the nurses
ignored me
my mother had to do everything from
keeping my incision clean to giving me
whatever food she could find
the hospital was poorly equipped and
filthy
to use the bathroom i had to get up and
cross an open courtyard to reach the
outhouse
at first i was too weak to stand
but once i was well enough to walk to
the bathroom
i discovered that the hospital used the
courtyard to store the dead
the whole time i was staying there
several bodies were stacked like wood
between my room and the outhouse
even more horrible were the rats that
feasted on them day and night
it was the most terrible sight i've ever
seen
the first thing the rats eat are the
eyes because that is the softest part of
the body
i can still see those hollow red eyes
they come to me and my nightmares and i
wake up scream
you still have those nightmares
you were 13 at the time
right after that how quickly did you
leave the country
after that incident at the hospital
within a week
the next day i took my stitch out the
next morning
i escaped
how much money and how many people knew
that you were leaving
no one knew not even my father
even myself did not know
my mother and myself we
my sister left a note and we were trying
to find where my sister went
and then we went that lady and she told
me that she was in china and she could
help us to go to china
and i heard my mom's hand that day that
she needs to come with me to china
because if i left her there i knew that
she was going to die
you couldn't barely walk no because i
just removed my stitches
and we had to climb these three big
here the mountains
then we had to cross this river waiting
until the dawn the darkness comes so we
could not just
like cross anywhere we had to go to the
vapor area where not many people are
coming by and also where the guard that
we brought
like uh
drives
is smuggling a big business in north
korea
because that's the only way you get
things
the the company is bankrupt
the system is bankrupt they don't make
things
and the guards don't give us things that
we need to smell things from china to
survive
and even
how where do you get clothes
if it doesn't come from china
there's a picture in your book
of you standing in pyongyang in front of
a palace or something
and you have a
t-shirt on that says princess in english
that was from china
that was and you were allowed to wear an
english not anymore
that so the government changes the
regulations
and even to this day the government
don't let people wear the things with
the english alphabet
and you can be punished for what you are
wearing what was the biggest surprise to
you once you got across the border the
biggest shock
i mean
the
thing
i mean the thing was like my mom was
raped in front of my eyes
that was uh
i did not know what that to us
i mean north korea the news talks about
all the good news we did not talk about
who got raped we did not talk about
there was a natural disaster we talk
about all the amazing things that was
happening in the socialist paradise
so to me to know what even rape was
to me to even know what that
act was
that was something that i unheard of on
on on thought like i never thought about
it
so
that
that was my first thing i saw outside of
north korea that seeing my mom was being
raped by this broker what was your view
of america and americans and did you
ever see it on a map
no i never seen the map of the world
i i i never said i did not even know
what africa was i did not know even
canada was and i did not know what in
las vegas it was
i knew vaguely they're americans
i mean they said the american bastards
all the time to us and that's how you
learn math yes i mean they say you know
how many americans you can care
and how and i knew about china and i
knew about russia maybe japan but like
that's all about it i did not know
what like in all other european
countries australia i mean i did not
even know how many the race that we had
i never seen the picture of colored
people or white people all i saw was
americans it was through the poster they
have like big nose and green eyes and
like it looks like monsters and they
told us that's what americans look like
and i don't have internet how do i go
check that's uh that's the truth or not
we're here in las vegas at freedom fest
what
the first time you came to vegas
what was going on in your mind just
given
what vegas is
it was overwhelming honestly
it was uh i mean people can build any
clues they want here and people really
live life
for
like really enjoying life i don't think
there's anything bad about it that's
what people do they should have freedom
to choose what they do
but i felt like that
i felt like so
i did not know how to even comprehend
this idea that
i feel like i'm seeing this two
different universe two different planets
that like we don't know if there's a
what's happening mars you know we know
vaguely but we do not understand what's
really going on
and to me it was like this gap
what is going to happen like this
humanity
moving forward
left out these 25 millions of people
they've been in this concentration camp
for 70 years
why
we are in this place where we went to
like moon we are going to mars and the
technology this
capital and this intelligence everything
they're moving us to a direction that we
don't even know where we are heading to
but it is unthinkable how we can just
like
same species we are all the same human
beings but it can be this different
and sometimes it really upset me to know
that how much things that we cared about
like we care about climate change you
care about equality you care about
animal rights we care about
so many things
and i couldn't understand why people had
no room for north korean people
why we have room for everything else but
not these 25 million people being
punished for their birthplace
i'm not saying that north korea is a
great disaster i mean things are bad in
venezuela things are bad like a lot of
other countries that that we need to
care about it but it just to me is
unthinkable that how this one country is
completely being forgotten from the rest
of the humanity
that's something i i i still like is a
question mark to me that
what's really going on why no one is
curious why they are curious about going
to mars but no one is curious to go to
north korea
freely without the government agents
well it looks like we might be moving
into a new
diplomatic world with north korea
that's uh
for politicians that is sure that they i
mean kim jong-un might come to white
house
but while he's doing that recently kim
jong-un executed another general
who said that we don't have to
develop more nukes because
we don't have to be studying because we
are going to start developing news
and that's what he got executed for
north korea has no intention
stopping the news
they they don't have no intention give
freedom to its own people
so that is not the direction that we are
going to i'm sure those politicians are
going to keep their status quo but the
people's suffering and the misery will
continue if we do not take action
yanmeet park what are you doing today
i'm a mother
i'm a student
and i
now i'm also running my own organization
with my
partner my co-defector from north korea
who actually was at the state of the
union
that i am trying to rescue my fellow
defectors who were trapped in china like
myself was
that we rescued them to the safety
and also we get information inside north
korea so we let the people know inside
north korea that they are slaves and the
rest of the world is this paradise they
are not in the socialist paradise
actually the place that we are in the
parish it is a paradise
so that's what i i do and i hope that
i do know that the change is not gonna
from the politicians if it was going to
work north korea was not gonna be this
way for 17 years if ever diplomacy were
like diplomacy work it would not work
that's why i believe that this class was
like a change that we need to save lives
and we need to change people first so
that real change will happen that north
korean people have to be leading this
movement to free themselves
that we cannot force that change ever we
can only empower that movement
you go to columbia university what are
you studying
now i'm human rights
and
you said you're a mother as well
i have a five-month-old a five-month-old
i am married to american ambassador
he's a real american
that's the thing like
they're all the same human beings
that it is when people come ask me so
why do i have to care about like north
korea
now it's clear because you might get
bombed by them someday
so if you're american you gotta care
about it
but before that's like because they're
like us like why if we can care about
the animal rights
that if that's how generous we are
does that ever makes question that we
cannot care about another human being
who just like dying for like a bottle of
rice who just being sold for like
hundred dollars at this point
we are we having this the where our
problems is like having too much
like what as a humanity we can say that
we are mortal animals like we are
different than animals we care about
other things
it's so i think it's really really to me
learning like what it means to be human
being through all this journey like it's
a constant question i'm asking myself
and i think that was a book that i
really read like by
a
man searching for meaning the holocaust
survivor that he says men was
created the holocaust they made these
people in the concentration camp and the
human beings are affected by the how is
possible
i will not know forever how was that
possible what's happening in north korea
right now that was committed by another
human being
but i know it's also possible that we
are the ones gonna free them i'm gonna
help them to be free
young me park is the author the book is
called in order to live thanks for
joining us on book tv thank you so much
for having me thank you for your
oh thank you so much for
giving me this platform
you're watching book tv on c-span 2
television for serious